President Trump is about to leave
Washington for trip to Europe he lands
tonight in Warsaw where he'll meet with
the presidents of Poland and Croatia
then he'll go to Hamburg Germany for the
g20 summit on Friday and Saturday mr.
Trump will meet with Chinese President
Xi and Russian President Putin in the
German city he says those countries need
to further isolate North Korea chip Reid
is at the White House chip good morning
well good morning the g20 summit is a
meeting of 20 of the world's most
powerful economies president Trump's
first appearance at the summit comes
amid increased provocations from North
Korea and that is likely to become the
focused instead of the world economy
there could be no greater privilege than
to serve as your commander in chief at a
4th of July celebration for military
families president Trump thanked
American troops serving at home and
abroad we do have challenges but we will
handle those challenges believe me the
biggest challenge right now that North
Korean missile launch Trump
administration officials held two
conference calls to discuss the
situation the only White House response
was the president's tweet does this guy
have anything better to do with his life
the UN Security Council will convene an
emergency meeting this afternoon UN
Ambassador nikki Haley tweeted Tuesday
spending my fourth in meetings all day
hashtag thanks North Korea Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson called for global
action in response to a global threat
adding that the US will never accept a
nuclear-armed North Korea the presidents
of Russia and China met in Moscow
Tuesday the two called for a freeze of
both North Korean nuclear testing and
joint military exercises by the US and
South Korea which are further flaring
tensions in the region at the end of the
day the Russians and the Chinese just
don't care it's not their problem
nuclear policy expert Jeffrey Lewis
believes increased sanctions or threats
will only push North Korea to develop
more weapons North Koreans realize that
these weapons are basically the only
thing they have going for them it's kind
of a fantasy to imagine that pressure
alone is going to solve our problem
president Trump has pressured China
to convince North Korea to stop
developing nuclear weapons and he is
reportedly deeply unhappy that China is
dragging its feet gal alright thank you
chip